non non ce n'est pas que je suis tu perds juste
la vitesse donc on ne fait pas
tellement le tour du cercle quoi oui ralentir ralentir ralentir
ralentir oh
oui scelle les
sceaux
trois à droite un à
gauche dophins ils tous  plonge
maintenant, as-tu vu des dauphins ou pas, on
dirait qu'ils ont une
peau blanche, euh, ça, je pense qu'ils
scellent l'eau en un clin d'œil oh,
nous volons toujours sur le cercle
si nous pouvions juste survoler s'il vous plaît  plutôt
que
euh qu'est-ce que tu
fais
ok
tu vas au filtre numéro un s'il te
plaît non non continue continue ok euh je
ne vois plus
G arrête d'enregistrer pour quoi ouais je l'ai eu
ouais disparu I oh ils sont de retour
à la mouette partout ici ouais c'est
vrai  là
ouais oh il y a
partout, nous n'avons pas vraiment de
photos d'eux assez bonnes pour rester,
pourquoi ne pas descendre plus bien, ils ne sont
debout que pour un instant, euh, arrête
d'enregistrer, je ne t'entends pas, ce que tu,
je
non, je veux dire  Je dis
les gars, ok, arrêtez d'enregistrer,
ralentissez simplement la vitesse de l'air,
je joue juste avec l'arrêt de
l'enregistrement, jouez simplement la
roue à filtres, ok, où était le euh,
ok, ralentissez, n'allez pas trop
loin,
ouais, vous avez  il
enregistre et j'en connais un autre à
euh 15h00 loin de là non euh assez
loin ce gu G maintenant tu le vois euh non non
c'est assez
loin sh ici ouais je l'ai je l'ai je l'ai je suis
en plein soleil  Je ne peux pas vraiment
les voir au soleil oui mais j'ai la victoire
je suis maintenant donc je dois y aller et
après je reviens ok plus bas et euh
plus lentement
je tire à 2h00 un un en
surface  ouais garde celui-là, on dirait qu'il
pourrait couler mais je ne pense pas
qu'il soit allé trop loin non non
c'est plutôt sympa en
transparence l'autre si tu veux n'est
pas euh est dehors ouais sur l'
eau et il y en a un troisième là-bas
aussi, je peux toujours voir le gars sous l'
eau ici et
j'espère que je monterai sur
scène, il y en a en fait trois en
diagonale assez loin les uns des autres
oh il y en a cinq parce que je vois
quelqu'un d'autre à gauche aussi, je ne sais pas
où rester  avec le gars ici pour lequel
je suis, il est en quelque sorte perdu,
euh, où est-ce que je
regarde, dis-moi où, dis-moi où
sont les autres, ils sont tous sous les
trois qui sont autour de nous, il doit
sortir pour un  je respire donc il
faut juste attendre ouais ouais
je
fais c'est un là-bas à 14h
juste à côté du
Shoreline ok euh c'est hors de l'
eau à
droite il monte tu le vois à
15h juste à côté du  glace là-bas
15h00 ok je suis je regarde à travers les
patins ok je le filme sur
notre ok sh un c'est
vrai ok
tu as compris ok
allons pour l'autre
arrêtons l'enregistrement c'est le canal d'expédition
euh si nous  pourrions nous retourner, pouvons-nous
y retourner, tu veux y retourner
ouais oui s'il te plaît ouais et bien tu vois tu vois sur
le rocher vers
le il y a un
joueur qu'est-ce que c'est
désolé là-bas, sois génial mais je ne le
ferai pas, il y a un
autre marqueur dessus  l'
autre île que vous voyez là-bas vers l'
autre île ouais, peu
importe quelle
île,
d'accord, pouvons-nous aller tout droit le long de
cette crête ici jusqu'à 3h00 le long de la
crête en regardant en arrière vers notre
droite non, c'est trop compliqué pour le
vent
hein ok ok
très proche du ouais 1h00
pour toi juste
là
qu'ils ont
disparu je joue polariz arrête d'
enregistrer
comme H au milieu du non non c'est euh
tu l'as là c'est là c'est ok
roule quatre oh sympa ça devrait  ce serait bien s'ils
apparaissent ici, ils contournent
le bord de la
glace là-bas, quatre d'entre eux,
d'accord,
reviennent, arrivent, arrivent, arrivent, arrivent
ici, contournent le
coin, pouvons-nous monter un peu plus haut, pouvons-nous
monter plus d'altitude et  regarde-les
un peu
plus raide que
possible non, c'est une bonne hauteur ici,
bonne hauteur ici, ils doivent
descendre, est-ce que
tu es Zuma, tu peux les avoir tous les deux ouais, en
tournant au
coin
presque, tu dois toujours
sortir mais tu
le manques  ok, tu sors au
milieu,
pourquoi oh,
ceux-là reculent
ici, oh,
ils sortent tous
[Music], ça a l'
air
bien ouais c'est vraiment sympa quand ils
marchent, je pense que oui, ça me semble bien en
regardant un autre
moniteur, j'ai un plan large ici ouais
montrant où ils
sont, donne-moi 10 secondes de
ça, ils
reprennent leur souffle, ils
reprennent leur souffle, ils reprennent leur souffle et les plans larges sont
bons, oh, nous pouvons les voir dans la façon dont ils ont pris la photo,
ouais, ouais,
d'accord, mais peut-être que je reste dans le
plan blanc parce que tu pourrais  je les vois vraiment ouais
non, je l'ai fait, j'ai eu environ 15 à 20
secondes de ça,
comme si j'allais sous le rocher, je
SP pour être
seulement
combien de glace nous avons encore sur tout le
littoral ici, allez pour
toujours, ils sont à l'ombre maintenant, euh, arrêtez
d'enregistrer jusqu'à ce que nous  reviens, j'en
ai une photo moyenne comme
ça, je
veux essayer, je veux risquer le
doubleur, eh bien, nous avons, nous avons une énorme
quantité de trucs, je pense que ça vaut le coup d'y aller, ouais, c'est vrai,
ok, tu es prêt à en faire
un, euh  un B ouais
ouais prêt tu veux y aller ouais
ok F reviens à un
c'était sympa avec le double ouais et bien
ce n'est pas ce n'est pas 100% tranchant pour le
pour le
w
étranger pour
spe
pour
ok quand toi je l'ai fait
peut-être en faire un autre  un pour
attendre, attends que je fasse surface ici,
je vais y aller, il y
a une petite tour Mark sur l'
hélicoptère P juste
là, je m'en
vais,
fais quelques gros plans, je pense qu'ils pourront se
rapprocher un peu,
jouer, je vais essayer de jouer avec
le  polariseur, vois ce que je peux
faire
ouais
pour
toi,
mais
ouais, pouvons-nous essayer de grimper un peu
et de les regarder de haut,
plus ouais par-dessus le sommet,
nous devons descendre ouais, d'accord, mais plus
l'hélicoptère au-dessus de la terre, euh  donc
les bélugas sont à notre position de 3h00 et
bas et même si nous pouvons en quelque sorte leur tirer
dessus, comme nous devrions les avoir à
notre position d'horloge de quatre ou cinq Lo, c'est
comme le tir maintenant, c'est un angle différent,
attendez  ici
depuis mon ombre c'est
ok ils ont changé de direction maintenant
ils se sont éloignés de l'
éclat ouais ils se sont éloignés du
rivage ils ont déménagé vers la mer peut-être
un peut-être euh en changeant d'hélicoptère
les ont ok arrête d'enregistrer